Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at whether
it's actually true that drinking alcohol is
a good way to warm yourself up on a cold day.
A common remedy to stave off frigid temperatures
on festive outdoor occasions is to drink alcohol.
But does drinking alcohol actually warm your
body?
In short, no, it does not.
In fact, drinking alcohol helps lower the
core temperature of your body.
The myth that alcohol warms you up likely
got its start thanks to the fact that drinking
alcoholic beverages will make you feel warmer
as your blood/alcohol level rises.
As the Director of Clinical Pharmacology at
the University of Iowa, Dr. William Haynes,
states, "Consumption of alcohol undoes many
of the human body's healthy reflexes, one
of which is keeping the core body temperature
warm in cold weather."
It doesn't even take that much for this effect
to kick in.
Even just one alcoholic drink will start the
process that results in a lowered core body
temperature.
So how does it do this and why does drinking
alcohol make you feel warmer, even though
you actually are getting colder?
Alcohol is a vasodilator, meaning that it
causes your blood vessels to dilate, particularly
the capillaries under the surface of your
skin.
Thus, the volume of blood brought to the skin's
surface increases, making you feel warm.
As Dr. Haynes mentioned, this overrides one
of your body's defenses against cold temperatures,
constricting your blood vessels, thereby minimizing
blood flow to your skin in order to keep your
core body temperature up.
While you may feel warmer from the extra blood
warming your skin (where most of your body's
thermoreceptors are located), this blood being
brought close to the surface of your skin
will be rapidly cooled if you are in a cold
environment (sometimes exacerbated by sweating
as a result of this heat flush).
The net effect is a rapid drop in core body
temperature, often without you even realizing
it as your skin will feel fairly warm, which
makes it doubly dangerous to drink alcohol
in extremely cold weather.
You can observe this dilation effect when
you see people who are slightly or fully intoxicated
looking flushed.
This effect is more extreme in some people
than others, so if you're one of those people
who gets flushed quickly when drinking even
small amounts of alcohol, you'll likely see
your core temperature drop even faster than
most when drinking in frigid environments.
This isn't the only bad thing about drinking
alcohol when cold.
According to a study done by the Army Research
Institute of Environmental Medicine, drinking
alcohol in cold weather also reduces the body's
ability and tendency to shiver, taking away
yet another method your body uses to help
keep warm when it is cold.
So, bottom line, the age old practice of drinking
alcoholic beverages to keep the body warm
in cold weather is the exact opposite of what
you should do in such a situation.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.